Thank you for sharing your responses. I
will be providing feedback on the forums periodically.
Now there are several ways in which to solve this problem. One way is for us
to write a program that somehow keeps track
of time, say two hours, and it essentially
does nothing during that time. So the first thing we want the program to do is
Wait for two hours.
And after we've waited for that amount of time, we
want the program to open up a web browser, which
plays let's say a YouTube video which is your friends
favorite song. So the second thing is to open a browser.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now because we want these two steps to happen multiple times
during the day. Because we want to take multiple breaks during the
day. We want to put these two steps inside some sort of
loop. So let's say we want to repeat these steps three times.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let's build this. I encourage you to follow along.